en ce joli mois de mai le mois de mai
typhaine qui lance traditionnellement la
saison des naissances et des cigognes je
fais bien la cigogne un achat fait bien
la cigogne qui amène les bons résultats
vous avez des idées de cadeaux pour les
bébés et leurs grands frères ou leurs
grandes soeurs tout cas vous avez trouvé
des livres
indestructible et pour le moins poétique
un tifo et oui et vous je ne sais pas si
vous saviez qu'il y avait des livres
indestructible pour bébé j'ai découvert
ça et c'est vrai écoutez vous savez on
hésite parfois à mettre des livres entre
les mains des bébés il ne faut pas parce
que plus jeune vous le faites et bien
plus et les adorons lire et j'ai trouvé
cette collection chez la maison
d'édition les deux coqs d'or figurent et
figurez vous qu'ils ont travaillé sur le
papier oui puisque c'est la base avant
de mettre un livre entre des petites
menottes et devoirs et bébé est risqué
de les porter à la bouche alors ce
papier est traitée avec un produit non
toxique pour le rendre un déchirant bhl
est étanche ont fait une démo vous
pouvez y aller au lieu d'un collage et
bien c'est une couture et vous le voyez
le papier n'est pas du tout alourdi
c'est un petit format qui tient dans les
petites mains si vous vous le mettez sur
le nez pas de risques de se blesser
c'est idéal vous pouvez laisser l'enfant
feuilleter ou lui raconter l'histoire
alors il ya plusieurs versions il y a
des cherche et trouve il ya des images
et comme vous le voyez et il ya même des
contes pour enfants comme boucle d'or ça
permet d'accompagner les enfants et bien
de l'âge de six mois jusqu'à la
maternelle c'est vraiment une super
collection elle s'appelle vous l'avez
dit un livre indestructible c'est une
innovation éditorial à saluer vraiment
ça rentre dans les bibliothèques les
sacs à dos vous le voyez c'est très fin
vraiment si vous avez une idée cadeau
affaire de six mois à quatre ans je
pense qu'on est bien n'hésitez pas
parfait en plus on l'a vu les couleurs
choisies sont pour le moins qu'ils nous
disant tu es ça vraiment moi j'adore en
plus vous l'avez dit aussi pour les
bébés tiphaine les éditeurs misent
souvent sur les couleurs de préférence
flashy c'est vrai qu'il faut que ça
flashe pour attirer les tout petits yeux
quand même oui alors question couleur
regarder su mener avec ce qu'il faut un
jeu ne pas projeter vers pas pro ce pop
c'est une série d'horreur petit à la
martinière jeunesse est alors bon les
titres et bien font référence aux
couleurs mais pas seulement parce que je
suppose que vous connaissez les livres
pop hits je vous en ai déjà parlé ce
sont ces livres qui font et bien jaillir
du papier au visage des enfants vous
voyez mais en général et bien c'est
réservé aux plus grands à partir de 5
ans parce qu'on a peur et bien que ce
soit déchiré parce que le papier est
trop fragile alors cette fois pas de
risque 1 c'est du carton c'est solide et
vous pourrez offrir ça à partir de
peut-être 18 mois j'ai envie de dire
c'est c'est une super idée ça permettra
est bien de découvrir les couleurs
puisque ce sont des petits imagier alors
l'idéal c'est d'offrir toute la
collection on y va on n'hésite pas et
puis en plus c'est assez drôle pour les
parents puisque évidemment pascal il y a
une petite question derrière tout ça est
ce que vous savez ce qui est rose moi je
dirais bien parce que j'ai quelqu'un qui
est quand même s'intéresse aux desserts
tirait bien un macaron un macaron ça
peut être rose dites moi oui tout à fait
macaron framboise ah c'est pas mal ça
c'est des moments à vous proposer pascal
mais il ya aussi la langue du chat
évidemment vous n'y aviez pas pensé je
suis sûr regarder non non le cochon
pourquoi pas au tien gauche aussi
heureuse regarder il est trop mignon ces
petits cochons regarder à et donc vous
avez pas du verre par hasard non si j'ai
divers et regarder aller je la fais ça
là
on était dans votre dessert tout à
l'heure
qui vous a permis de décrocher la
timbale mode
savez rapport avec avec la grenouille
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure oui
derrière nous il s'avère tout à fait bon
parfait mettez souvent d'un coup on est
les seuls à occuper oui il faut toujours
amener une petite touche champêtre
bompard fait je crois qu'elle est dans
l'herbe la carène mais regardez à l'est
pas mal cette grenouille on dirait moi
le matin dit dans parfait c'est tout ce
que vous avez la lna revient avec les du
très très très grand format ah oui ça
c'est bien un peu de poésie du matin ça
va tout de suite nous faire du bien j'ai
l'impression que c'est des livres xxl à
lire à deux dans une collection qui en
dit long si j'en crois mes yeux mes
petits yeux 0 3 ans et c'est bon pour
les bébés c'est ça oui alors c'est une
collection qui a été pensée par seuil
jeunesse à partir des dernières études
sur les bébés figurez vous que les bébés
voient mieux le noir et blanc puisque
leur oeil n'est pas complètement formés
et adore les ritournelles et la
musicalité de la langue ça vous l'avez
sûrement éprouvé en leur racontant des
petites chansons alors ils sont allés
voir l'auteur jeunesse thierry dedieu et
ils l'ont soumis ces constatations et
voilà ce qui est née poèmes pour les
bébés haïku de printemps et bonne
anniversaire alors haïku de printemps
par exemple eh bien c'est ce grand livre
avec de jolies illustrations en noir et
blanc sur lequel on peut se coucher un
tout en jouant aux petites voitures par
exemple et en écoutant est bien joli
poème raconté par ses parents et en
regardant ces jolies illustrations en
noir et blanc alors vous le voyez hein
c'est un très grand format on est aux
extrémités des deux précédents livres
mais vraiment c'est un livre très très
agréable à regarder à lire qui plaira
aux enfants à partir de 6 mois quand il
commence à tenir assis ou à crapahuter
un peu partout vers 9 mois 18 mois voilà
on peut y aller jusqu'à la maternelle
donc vous le voyez un tous ces petits
livres pour vous montrer que les
éditeurs n'hésitent plus à innover à
aller dans tous les territoires et bien
pour les enfants et puis voilà papier
couleur noir et blanc il ya tout ce que
vous voulez moi j'adore la sélection
livre de la région et d'ailleurs à
retrouver aussi sur le net et évidemment
les réseaux sociaux avec et tiphaine
sypher qui vient chaque mois nous ouvrir
les bibliothèques de vous êtes
formidables